templates bei den siebziger jahren hat
rudi carrell dem prozess vorgesungen
wann wird's mal wieder richtig sommer
musste er deswegen sterben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir erklären was chemtrails sind und was
die auslösen
ja ich denke schon das sind streifen die
sich am himmel bilden die meisten leute
denken das sind normale kondensstreifen
sind verschiedene giftstoffe drin soweit
ich weiß
die atmen wie ein ihr kameramann wir
alle
tatsächlich fällt ihr auch dass heute
der himmel komplett dichtes naja weiter
sind das sind das die camp habe ich bin
die ganze zeit sieht man doch leuchtet
dann droht schillern einfahren ich
glaube die lüge fängt viel früher an
ich glaube ihr flugzeug können überhaupt
nicht liegen sind nämlich viel zu schwer
wenn die unten sind geht es noch weil
die luft drückt von unten gegen hoch
sobald man sagt diesen oben ja ab einer
gewissen hosen der braucht man diese
schenkkreis auch als kissen flugzeuge so
bei sonst könnt ihr gar nicht lieben
werden sich die lügenpack eine invasion
oder lügen presse kein internet
wer steuert das denn usa us militär
wollen uns als bevölkerung reduzieren
die sitzen da oben und sie sagen sich es
gibt zu viele menschen vor allem in
europa wenn wir die gesamte menschheit
auf masse australischen kontinent
unterbringen wenn es etwa so nicht
erfüllt wie münchen und ich war in
münchen benannt keinen angestoßen kann
also nicht zu eng sein dann ist der rest
des planeten frei für landwirtschaft
oder sonstiges also alle nach australien
nur eine religion und manche gucken ob
wir zu viele menschen auf diesem
planeten haben wir gerade
eigentumswohnung gekauft interessiert
mich nicht
ihr seid doch bezahlt wir werden die den
menschenrechten entsprechend weil die
deutschen mit dem personalausweis nach
jetzt auch im rennen deswegen könnt ihr
die menschenrechte brechen und ihr könnt
ihr trost kohle kassieren
und wer will es ihm aber ich musste auch
geld verdienen wenn sie geteilt werde
ich dann auch nicht mehr blühen und mit
auslastungen von wahrheiten er weiter
die ich kein geld
kentridge bei den siebziger jahren dann
hat die carell im prozess lösungen wann
wird's mal wieder richtig sommer musste
er deswegen sterben kann ja sein das
wäre lächerlich genau wie michael
jackson und so die interesse war zwar da
so meine sechste loszuwerden aber so auf
kempters nein nur weil der hat die auch
die totale aufklärung gemacht innerhalb
in der popmusik
die politik ist total unterhalten
also lady gaga ist die schirmherrin von
dieser ganzen illuminaten mutter von
blabla chemtrails sind ja gegen die
klimakatastrophe das heißt sie
demonstrieren im prinzip für die
klimakatastrophe
ach so auch bisher interessant aber es
gibt die nicht ich weiß was gibt die
nicht wirklich oft nach und sie bauen
sind sie heute hier bin hier um dich zu
beobachten
ach so warum war ich auf sich aufpassen
sollte dass du kein quatsch macht hier
fragen stellt die leute nicht fest
deswegen bin ich hier
[Musik]
was ich da